tilting against the defenders for sure
yeah if you can score 131 points like
the Rockies did a couple of nights ago
you're gonna win every game I suppose
turn Wow man for [ __ ] here's the
challenge that's the challenge there
great job being protective there by
turning what a pass by Oladipo to a
cutting Evitts they opened up a double
take your lead and they did maintaining
their concentration on both sides of the
ball off solid defense then again
protecting that realm there's Myles
Turner I mean really solid job you can
see right here good cut Myles Turner
comes over and put texture
[Applause]
the symptoms of boobs ashen there by the
pace of scrambling around partner it
come back wind a good a heck of a wind
guy that get the shot and then it goes
back out people get it but now use this
money time so folks don't get there how
about your center out and just cover
that off
sirs pushing it back the other way
Simmons and he turns it over
Turner by himself
defense is incredible but you are
driving into three yellow jerseys
nobody's expecting that truck
it is pretty depth defensively into the
paint and Turner with a little payback
hands on at 8:00 to shoes wince low back
in
and recycle by Myles Turner
[Applause]
- Carla so bogey to get the ball
the Hornets ran the exact same play and
they ended up uh one good basketball
thereby anyhow they ended up with the
turnover on the heart of the Kimble
Walker the first one Kendall Walker
maybe made an effort to flip I'm at
least
[Music]
[Applause]
from Collison and for the Pacers Myles
Turner has six early points first
quarter in Charlotte Cleveland where he
comes down off the dribble F don't miss
all the way to go is Turner
yeah till they stop you better take
advantage of it in here early victim
miles on the strong finish in the sack
City
you know from your parents to the
balance of your family
and all that comes into play and that's
Turner from wrapping his third block
shot to listen to a couple of times but
I understand what you're saying
Carlson gets to the baseline inside for
the dunk in Turner
apt and rebound tip to wags Green has it
this is a little bit tougher team they
have a rock climber let it get by they
came in hammered
and what's incredible is the recovery
he's able to get back that ball is
barely out of the hand and now running
his field it gets there make sure he
cleans it up this is an extent at home
against Milwaukee in New Orleans and has
won at Memphis and Boston as Turner
second time we've seen him get behind
his own seven times he paid five
three-pointers a year ago cognition
defense goes underneath you got to take
you got to take the shot I don't think
there's any question as you can see it
looks like Lin's gonna have any memory
got to it
my turn and that leads to a run-out laya
per game he has 16 double doubles this
year he and char teen last night 11 in
the third quarter Williams down the lane
midair by way to get it fun need to feel
it real but it is a big time block and I
don't believe Williams will be going in
there as Ibaka grabs the rebound
Indiana's [ __ ] had 48
in the winter there's weather away Loch
Ness his brother but he wiped it clean
but one game there is Turner right there
at the top here's a four-on-three
come over that ball barely used the hand
and he stops it on the glass and then
press something Chris he controls around
that wouldn't go in after he made his
first to the night with the rebound
I was playing big on the inside is able
to get in there and get his hands on the
ball the only question is yeah that's
basket in the pants that wasn't cold so
a black in the fact that the Pacers to
get this couple fresh holiday turns the
corner
by Turner what a terrific pass by
Thaddeus jump start with high hands
active hands best shot blocker and the
league is able to get that one before it
gets to the glass by Holliday with that
kind of strength in the second half he's
got this he didn't care who was this is
what this is one of the things you miss
it when you don't have it deep freeze to
turn your back on them
miles got to the room 11 first quarter
points it's big for us here in the first
day first morning
13 points five rebounds six assists for
James to turn 34 yeah for sure all the
day it's mother chicken oh did he give
it one on that and then get it on the
other than in it and Deborah's it down
where the cover up Victor down at Miami
has a big smile doesn't he told Wallace
that's blocked away
slapped on the glass
you need time I've got to really seal
the game for the paper win for the paper
mill just Alexander Edson and that's
Turner again his third block Thursday
night against the Timberwolves turn her
down the way sure did with Isaac's at
the rim Turner anyone in Toronto
now Ross hasn't shot clock at four and
block by Turner that's his fourth Matt's
just season-high with 23 of the lost
were laced up and it's blocked by Turner
frickin great block by Myles - he got
Levine shot has McDonough [ __ ] lays it
a scored 47 with nine rebounds at night
assists he made six threes Turner down
the lane and pouch at home
he was a good because I looked at it I
didn't think marketing could get there
ion's takes advantage of that move to
get to the rim strong benefit our show
today and he's talking about his
relationship behind his mother and his
father is where he got his toughness
from Washington's mother go to work
every day the bear that she took on and
that responsibility he can't give up or
turn around because he's seen how hard
his parents work right there
get one for mom and dad and the bumps
two and a half game chefs one of only
two points in the paint tonight
McDonough Sanford Ikuko that package is
17
physically they played him with two
dissenters they
with
we thought in his foul the other players
foul mark Brogdon here by Joseph even
the voice work the fallout buried the
free-throw line with a left hand missed
it and Turner the rebound he's gonna
bring it all the way down the floor on
his birthday
the whole bits jumped up on that one
then they should never gives it up does
a good job see the opening see it fill
it be it happy birthday
[Music]
locked again my turn over turn
really good job here cuz it looked like
it was gonna be a dump
if miles comes back it gets another
block is his for he was passing that too
to Drummond Reggie Jackson had three
fouls it down Lane
don't get in a foul what about Evans in
his view so he didn't play much but
coming down on this fast break and look
up then 58% in threes taking horror game
command it's been tutored and mentored
[Applause]
keep an eye on us now let's turn to
complying by his man down baby he's up
over the top little forearm action there
they call that clearing space what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
Bleacher Report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content